fortnight is back and making a splash
with season three splashdown with all
the commotion over figuring out just
exactly what is new for players when
they log in we quickly go over the six
biggest changes in Chapter two season
three
a new season means a new map and
although you may recognize most of the
areas a significant portion of the map
is now underwater areas that were
previously at sea level are now
completely swamped or left in shambles
like the rickety rig and the fertility
meanwhile though situated at a higher
elevation remain comfortably safe which
means you won't have to be scrambling to
find a boat to navigate around retail
row or lazy Lakes
the next significant change is the
introduction of loot sharks and yes you
heard me correctly loot sharks are these
massive tanky sharks that swim around
the flooded areas will aggressively
pursue you if you're standing close to
the edge of the water trust us the first
time one came flying out of the water to
slide across a wooden deck to try and
tear us apart we were pretty shocked too
the good thing about these loot sharks
though is as their name implies they go
around eating up all the loot left
behind in the water so it's potentially
worth taking them out in order to get
what they've got hold up a fun thing you
can do is even use a fishing pole to
bait the shark and use it as a means to
traverse across the water even faster
now last season we had Deadpool
challenges but this season we have
something even better Jason Momoa the
Aquaman you know and love is now the
featured skin in season 3 he will have
his own set of challenges separate from
the general weekly set and completing
all of them throughout the course of the
season will net you not just as
Aquaman's skin but an Arthur curry
variant as well we also get one brand
new weapon and the return of an old
favorite the charged shotgun and the
hunting rifle the charged shotgun has
three in the chamber before you're
forced to reload so you can hold down
the trigger in order to give the gun
more punch in its shot while tightening
the spread and reducing recoil meanwhile
the hunting rifle a bolt-action weapon
without a scope that packs a serious
punch returns from the vault we're all
ready we're getting reactions from some
of fortnight's streamers on his return
most of them favorable this season three
a new battle pass makes his debut and
all the themed banner scans and gliders
reflect the changes to the season but
there seems to be a mix of older skins
as well as you level up the battle pass
you can continue to grind out XP to
unlock more
variance to make unassuming skins look
even better there's also a lore theme
with some of the skins being connected
to characters from season two so just
get the robot using kitten who's
following in his dad's footsteps
lastly the central hub with all of the
challenges and seasonal goodies has been
overhauled challenges are now in three
sets with general weekly challenges
style challenges and Aquaman challenges
all coming together to ensure that
players always have something to grind
for in order to receive XP or cosmetic
rewards you can even design the victory
umbrella glider with the Builder Brella
feature certain rewards in the battle
path will unlock upgrades to the shaft
canopy and even trail effects to really
set your creative flair and make the
victory umbrella your own there sure to
be more limited time modes and other
surprises throughout the season and
we're excited to see what port Knight
has up its sleeve let us know in the
comments below if you think the new
direction of fortnight season 3
splashdown theme is interesting or if
you preferred the days of the agency
we'll be putting out weekly guides to
help those of you looking to complete
the more difficult weekly challenges so
stay tuned to game spot
[Music]
you